Qué posibilidades reales hay de que el
congreso peruano acepte esta solicitud
de boluarte de realizar elecciones
anticipadas
es un desenlace que se va a dar digamos
ahora el congreso ha entrado en receso
para poder encontrar una salida pero es
de no hacerlo creo que las protestas
podrían terminar con la renuncia de de
boluarte lo que haría que los comicios
sean aún más temprano Así que creo que
lo más ordenado es que lo es que
aprueben esta propuesta y puedan dar una
salida a la crisis que se tiene Bueno
pero realmente la mandataria tiene
formas de permanecer en la presidencia o
veremos en los próximos días y semanas
una lucha por sacarla del cargo
bueno en el congreso lamentablemente es
una información que empieza a circular
que digamos este nudo una de las
motivaciones que tendría es precisamente
forzar su salida ella eh ha juramentado
un gabinete que que hoy cumple hecho una
semana lamentablemente no ha dado salida
estas violentas protestas la mitad de
las víctimas han muerto en carreteras
por bloqueos es decir gente que no podía
recibir atención médica y enfrente una
situación muy compleja porque no tiene
bancada tiene un equipo de gobierno
inexperto en términos políticos sí
sólido lo técnico
en consecuencia no es una no es una
posición tan cómoda
la salida de hoy hoy en la mañana en
horas Lima habló con la prensa que es lo
que los titulares han recogido eh de
alguna manera puesto o ha enfatizado la
responsabilidad que tiene el congreso y
esperemos que eso fortalezca su posición
y también
prepare esta seguidilla inestabilidad
que el país ha tenido y cómo se puede
analizar el actuar del gobierno y de las
fuerzas armadas en medio de estas
protestas Pues que dejan esta veintena
de muertos y cientos de heridos
Mira el gobierno Lamentablemente demoró
mucho implementar medidas correctivas y
en muchos casos Parece que la que la
represión se le ha ido de las manos a
estas alturas ya te diría que por lo
menos en las zonas urbanas las cosas
parecen estar controladas me refiero a
la jornada de hoy ayer y el día ante
previo han sido violento
algo que algunos abusos que seguramente
en su momento se se investigarán ayer en
cualquier caso también el consejo de
estado salió a respaldar el el papel que
viene jugando las fuerzas armadas pero
vamos a ver cómo cómo siguen los días